Have you ever been told that you look like someone famous?
Of course you have!
Now there is a website that uses face recognition software...
...and compares your face to hundreds of celebrity faces in their database.
It's easy and fun.
More importantly, you can find out how true your friends flattery really was.
Face recognition runs in 3 steps.
One, the digital photo that you provide is loaded.
Two, face detection technology is applied to automatically detect human faces in your photo.
Three, face recognition technology is applied to recognize...
...the faces detected in the previous step.
Algorithms compare the faces in your photo...
...with all faces previously known to the face recognition database...
...and then they are matched with the celebrities' with your bone and facial patterns.
The more photos are added to the system, the more powerful it becomes.
If people in your photos are not recognized well,...
...it is likely that the database has never encountered them before.
By adding your photos to this database and annotating the people in the photo manually,...
...the database operators will "learn" these faces...
...and will be able to recognize them in future photos,...
...even in different ages of the same person's life.
The algorithms used by database operators face recognition software...
...are even likely to find relatives of people in your photo,...
...due to the genetic - based facial similarities that exist between relatives.
You might even be able to use this to form connections between people whom you never even knew were related.